[Music]
so often when I pull up to a gas station
I'll have an eighteen-year-old kid come
up to me and say oh my gosh you know
how'd you get a rolls-royce like the
sort of Lambo or the Ferrari or the i8
and how did you make your money and what
did you do and they have no idea what
happened prior to it for 18 20 years of
making decision so finally I said what I
tell these eighteen year olds these 19
years I want to make a video of it so
you can all exactly since many of your
graduating from high school if you have
a friend or kid somebody share this
video with them look probably the best
advice I can give you is there are
certain things you have to take your
time in you gotta take your time in the
following six things one marriage take
your time you're still learning what the
word love is you start learning what you
want what you don't want and who the
data who not to date you may have a
boyfriend you're loved right now you
think you love right now but 10 years
from now he's gonna have three four
qualities you do not like about this
person take your time you may have a
girlfriend you love right now but take
your time with marriage take your time
with kids take your time with buying a
house you may not live in the place
you're at you may get an opportunity six
months 12 months 24 months 36 months
from now we can move to a whole
different place take your time with
buying the house take your time with
your inner circle on who your friends
are many of your current friends will
not be your friends 5 10 years from now
and if you're not too careful many of
them will hold you back from getting to
exactly where you want to get to believe
me it wasn't easy me having to tell some
of my friends to stop calling me on
Friday nights and Saturday nights then
I'm no longer going to the clubs I made
them very upset but I wanted to go to a
whole different place take your time
with your political beliefs most of your
political beliefs are different it'll
it's going to be very different when you
pay $100,000 in taxes and you realize
who is really working card and
capitalizing off the system that you
have in your country and who is not and
last but not least take your time with
your life purpose my purpose took me a
long time until God I got clear on what
I wanted to do I see so many people
trying to get everything right now
especially with the social media world
that we're living in but take your time
in those areas take your time now what
areas you shouldn't take your time in is
the following don't take your time
learning about hard work go learn hard
work learn what it is to work 80 hours a
week go learn about hustle go learn
about studying people watch everybody
study everybody
study your parents study your cousin's
study that uncle of yours that does so
good and at the dinner table don't say
anything just watch them ask him
questions when you work with a guy CEO
that's doing very good just ask him
watch how he handles meetings watch how
he handles in certain challenges issues
study people your entire games gonna be
studying human nature because if you're
gonna move up you're gonna deal it with
the number one product in the world
which is people so study people study
communication how you relay your message
to everybody most your life your parents
your kids your wife your boyfriend your
girlfriend your customers your investors
your business owners your boss you're
gonna have to learn how to communicate
and learn how to communicate fast don't
take your time on learning how to
communicate get that down now study
yourself study what you like study what
you don't like study what kind of people
to rub you the wrong way study what kind
of people you get along with find
somebody you want to model find somebody
that's way ahead of you and say oh my
gosh I just love watching this guy how
he handles himself find a group of
people with certain ways they live and
model them and by the way as far as
experimenting let me give you one thing
I would tell you to stay away from a
hundred percent and that is drugs
alcohol stay away from any man-made
drugs and alcohol because they mess with
your mind
and the most biggest thing as I'm
telling you all this stuff when you see
it alive people say how do you live in a
fifteen thousand square foot home how do
you have this business how do you have
all this stuff that you're doing it's
the period from eighteen to thirty nine
the decisions that were made during that
period it's purely a combination of
decisions I've made a lot of bad
decisions but I was lucky enough to take
my time in marriage in kids and my
purpose in buying a house in my circle
in my political beliefs because I was in
learning mode I was an ego to say I know
everything I was in learning mode and
then obviously things became more solid
strong foundation I was able to get
exactly what I wanted in my life because
I took my time with those six things and
I was very urgent with the other things
that helped me get to where I'm at today
so again if you're from high school and
you're about to graduate high school
right now this is what I want to do
which I want you to watch the video the
one-page business plan Mario's gonna put
the link below once you watch the
one-page business plan I want you to
write it up and tweet me at Patrick big
David the fact that you have your
one-page business plan with your cell
phone number
three of you I'm personally gonna call
you we're gonna have a 15-minute
conversation together three of you but
the first thing you got to do is go
watch the one-page business plan video
write up your one page business plan
tweet me out Patrick waited with your
phone number and three of you I'll
personally call Youm have a conversation
together about what you could do next to
live the exact life that you want to
live take everybody